all right so I think I think Joe Biden
is the Democrats best chance of winning
in 2020 which you know is not he's not
exactly brilliant political analysis of
my part it's what most people think and
but except that the Democrats are in the
process of chewing him up right now and
spitting them out they are they are
eating their best candidate alive right
now we're going to talk about that in a
second but before we get into that I
want to give you a word from our friends
over at Duke cannon now Duke cannon is
great because it's pretty much the
manliest possible name for a company
that you can imagine the only thing
manlier would be maybe something like
rifle whiskey bacon or so that which
actually would just be a great flavor of
whiskey now that I think about it but
anyway speaking of manliness and rifles
actually Duke cannon superior quality
grooming goods for hardworking men are
tested by soldiers so Duke cannon
partners with active duty military and
they developed these ideas and they
review products and anything that
doesn't meet the standards and
expectations of our soldiers then just
isn't going to happen it's thrown on the
thrown on the on the cutting room floor
Duke cannon sells basically everything
everything you need nothing you don't my
favorite Duke cannon product personally
is the is the beard wash and also the
beard balm which you know you always got
to carry your beard ball around with you
if you're a beardsman like I am you got
to have your balm
smells like arm wrestling and
Lumberjacks it's just it's a it's a
wonderful product your beard is a
precious thing and so you need to take
care of it they also have shaving cream
if you're into that kind of thing they
have deodorant they have cologne I Ward
the Cologne the other day and I went as
I went to the store and I was walking by
a guy and the guy stops for a minute it
goes what's that smell is it smells like
America and I said you're damn right
it's a real conversation folks that
really happened visit Duke canon right
now if you want to smell like
Lumberjacks and America and get 15% off
your first order with the promo code
Walsh its 15% off the first order promo
code Walsh at Duke
Kanon calm free shipping on orders over
$35 Duke Canon comm go there now okay so
the media is is now discovering that Joe
Biden is racist allegedly supposedly a
discovery that seems sort of odd given
the timing you know the guy has been in
politics for I think it's I think it's
about 673 years I think it exactly has
been in politics since you know way into
the Middle Ages and none of this stuff
came up for all those centuries nobody
brought up anything about Joe Biden
being racist but now that he's
threatening to take the nomination away
from more liberal candidates like Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren Camilla
Harris whoever now it's all coming to
light kind of interesting by just a
coincidence I'm sure right it's it's not
like the media's acting as an oppo team
for the far-left Deford far-left
Democratic candidates I mean that's of
course they would never do that I would
there's no possible way so they've been
digging up supposedly racist dirt on Joe
Biden and you've heard about a lot of it
already I'm sure here's the latest the
headlines yesterday
well here's just one headline in media
i'ts headline said joe biden once
referred to jesse jackson as that boy in
unearthed report he called Jesse Jackson
that boy that sounds bad right obviously
for a white man to call black man boys
that's especially say that boy had that
boy over there Jesse Jackson
that sounds really racist and terrible
right but the headline is total BS of
course it's true that he did call Jesse
Jackson that boy but if you listen to
the context here is the context reading
from the article says Jackson Jackson is
one of the brightest guys around Biden
said in remarks made after a speech that
boy ain't no dummy
just like Gary Hart that boy ain't no
dummy either Gary Hart by the way is
white so he referred to a white guy as
that boy
in the very same sentence that we refer
to a black guy is that boy which means
that it's not racist it's nothing racial
going on here
that boy is it's a colloquialism it's
like if you referred to a woman and you
said you know you go girl or something
to a woman and then of course it'll be
ridiculous for the woman to say Oh Jews
call me a girl not a girl I'm a grown
woman now it's it's an expression it's
meant to be a supportive kind of funny
just colloquial expression I think we
all understand that so in that context
oh that boy ain't no dummy I'll tell you
that not racist but the media knows that
but they're going with it anyway because
they're trying to destroy Joe Biden
plenty of conservatives as well you know
it's kind of a the the enemy of my enemy
is a sort of thing going on so
conservative so usually complain about
fake news and media bias and when
misleading headlines and everything but
a lot of conservatives are spreading
this this this stuff too and going along
with this I go look at this Joe Biden
called Jesse Jackson boy that's so
racist now they all know better of
course they know that it's bogus but
they're doing it anyway and that's why I
hate I hate politics I hate the bad
faith arguing everybody argues in bad
faith and I get it okay I strategically
I understand I'm not stupid I get why
conservatives are pretending to think
that Joe Biden is racist he's not racist
he's a lot of things many of them not
good there's no reason to think that
he's actually racist and if you're a
conservative especially you know you
know that you know that he's not red you
never was saying that about him before
you don't actually think he's racist
you're just saying that now because he's
probably the biggest threat to President
Trump and so you figure well we could
get rid of him in the primaries we don't
have to worry about him in the general
election strategically I get it so
that's why you're going up to the
Liberals and saying hey you know Joe
Biden over there it's kind of a racist
isn't he I don't know that guy over
there seems kind of racist I mean it's
it's not my problem is just I'm just
letting you guys know you might want to
do something about uncle racist over
there
I understand strategically but I
personally I can't I just I can't get
myself to the point where integrity
means not
thing to me and I don't mean I'm not
putting myself on a pedestal this isn't
a holier than dial thing I just I I
can't I can't get there I think a lot of
conservatives have gotten there where
ends justify the means honesty means
another thing the truth means nothing
we're just trying to win but you see the
problem with that is well number one
it's morally wrong so I mean that should
matter
that's it should matter to conservatives
when something is morally wrong but
number two it's strategically it's
actually very stupid because the whole
thing we're trying to fight against in
our culture is this morally relativistic
truth doesn't matter ends justify the
means mentality that's the philosophy
the worldview that the left is trying to
establish and it's what we're trying to
fight against so if we become that also
if we adopt that also then we lose they
win even if we get a Republican in there
if we have adopted their worldview if we
have become essentially leftist
ourselves then there isn't there's
nothing but leftists all around leftist
to the right of me left us to the left
of me and they win they have won it
doesn't matter at that point if you get
a Republican in there if they have
completely won the culture because we've
given up and thrown in the towel and
said yeah we might as well just yes sure
whatever we'll just go along with you
and who cares it doesn't matter don't
you see that that's the point that some
conservatives have been trying to make
for a long time now well from what's
frustrating for us because it seems so
obvious but there is a school of thought
among some conservatives that the only
thing that matters is winning and so
forget about truth forget about honesty
forget about all that doesn't matter the
left doesn't play by that by those rules
why should we well know those of us on
the other side of that fence it's not
like we're squeamish or something like
we're afraid to mix it up and fight for
our cause I think you know that about me
by now I'm not as I'm not afraid to say
anything I'll have these arguments I'm
not squeamish about any of this stuff
I'm just saying in my mind
this is exactly what we're opposing if
we become what we oppose then there's no
point anymore I am my mission is not to
get Republicans elected that's not what
I'm all about
all right also of course the problem is
that when you take people out of context
and you try to paint them as racist even
though you know better you can't really
act outraged and offended when the same
is done to your side I mean you can but
why would anyone take you seriously and
that's why nothing matters anymore
nothing gets done no conversation goes
anywhere arguments lead to nothing
neither side has any credibility on
anything anymore and that's the problem
we're all just we've all just punted our
integrity 100 miles away we're
pretending to be offended by the exact
sorts of things that we do and say
ourselves so we play the game and accuse
the other side of being the only one
that plays it when we know that's not
true and everyone knows that everyone
else is full of it
we're all looking at each other knowing
that the person across the table is full
of it and they know that we're full of
it and this is so it doesn't matter I
say this by the way as someone who
strongly dislikes Joe Biden I think that
he's a tease he'd be a terrible
president I think that he's a bad
politician I don't like him as a person
I think he's a coward among other things
I mean this is the guy that abandoned he
for 50 years he held a position against
taxpayer funding for abortion and now
he's become a you know radical feminist
pro-abortion militant just because
that's because he's trying to appease
his base that's cowardly and so I have
no respect for that but racist there's
no evidence of that just because I don't
like him and I oppose him it doesn't
mean that every insult and every
accusation lobbed against him is
automatically true so evidence that he's
raised oh he said that he worked with
segregationist so what it wasn't he
didn't I clearly was not mentally he
wasn't saying oh yeah you know I because
I agreed with segregate you think he'd
been coming out saying he agrees with
segregation even that was true why in
the world would he say it that wasn't
the point
making he was trying was insulting
Republicans he was trying the way that I
read it is that he was he was saying
yeah you know we got to work with
Republicans now and hey I don't like it
but I can do it I mean I had to work
with segregations and Chris
segregationists back in the day which
yeah if you were in Congress in the
early 70s you had to work with
segregationist that doesn't mean that
you're racist it just means that you're
old and so he was really smearing
Republicans in a dishonest way himself
and we should oppose that but we
shouldn't oppose it by pretending that
we think that what he said was racist
that maybe he was really coming out in
favor of segregation or something when
we know that isn't true so much of the
political discourse you know you ever
have you ever been talking to somebody
who's lying to you and you know that
they're lying to you and they know that
you know that they're lying but they're
continuing the lie and you're just
looking them in the eyes and you both
know what what the score is and so
parents go through this a lot actually
with with you know parents if you're a
parent disease it happens a lot of time
a lot a lot with kids and I think
they're pulling something over on you
but then you've got them caught and then
they start to realize that oh they're
caught but they stick with the story and
you know so that happens I think that
our political discourse is a lot like
that where we're both just lying and
pretending to think things we don't
think and pretending to be offended by
things we aren't really offended by
saying spewing talking points that we
don't really believe and we're saying
this to each other and look at each
other in the eyes but we both know that
the other person is full of it and they
don't really mean it and so there's this
mutual understanding unspoken that we're
both just really lying and I don't know
at a certain point you just get tired of
it you said I don't know why am I even
gonna have this conversation teen
anything speaking of dishonesty here's a
headline from the hill the headline is
Laura Ingraham dismisses reparations for
slaves and ins we won you lost so the
headline is that's quoting her that she
said we won you lost so based on the
headline
and it sounds like well it sounds pretty
bad it sounds like Laura Ingraham is
referring to slavery and saying we won
you lost she's referring to slave
descendants she's saying sorry too bad
we won you lost sorry about the slavery
that's what that's what they're making
it sound like she said which is
incredibly racist you think this woman
Lilly lose her mind again even if she is
that racist why would she say that
publicly so that's what you think if you
just read the headline that this is an
incredibly racist woman who said
something monstrous but that of course
is not actually what happened if you
read the article you discover that this
headline is flatly dishonest and lying
that is not what she said let's read the
article that the hill provides says Fox
News is Laura Ingraham dismissed the
idea of reparations for the descendants
of slaves on her podcast Thursday as do
overs Ingram played a clip Thursday of
author to Chyna Houston Coates blasting
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
engrams gasps Kentucky State professor
Wilfred Reilly said reparations would
open the door to Native Americans
calling for the same Riley said I mean
obviously both white and black soldiers
frankly took this country from the
Indians the first people Ingram
responded people would argue that the
whole world and I would the whole world
has been reshaped by people taking other
people's land it's called conquest there
was an argument some time I think it was
in the 1980s there was a quote
describing world politics we won you
lost that's that and that's just the way
it is she added okay so the we we won
you lost was not in reference to slavery
it was not in reference to reparations
it was not in reference to the slave
descendants it was in reference to
conquest and she was quote she was
paraphrased phrasing a quote in
reference to conquest and basically
saying this was the way of the world for
thousands of years and she's right about
that that was the way of the world
conquest every everyone did it doesn't
make it right but this is the point I've
made before that for us to sit back and
and
the Mon Europeans and whites stealing
land and so on okay fine you could do
that but then you you have to also say
the same about literally everybody every
other culture and country and society on
the planet for thousands of years that's
that's what everybody did the way
humanity worked it's the way that
societies grew through war and conquest
doesn't make it good doesn't make it
okay but you have to look at it in
historical context that's what she's
saying she is not talking about slavery
and saying you lost so this headline is
not not just misleading it's it's it's
libelous because the people who write
the headlines they know okay they know
that most people are not gonna bother to
actually read the article right most
people aren't gonna bother to read the
article what most people do is they just
they just they they read the headline
and they think and they react to it and
they say oh that's terrible how could
Laurie Egret it and then and then rather
than moving on they actually still share
even though they haven't read it they
share it not taking any time to actually
investigate it for themselves they'll
still share it and then pass on the
misleading information and of course the
media knows that that's the way that it
works
and so they they know that they can they
can put whatever they want into a
headline and they can they could put it
in the headline and then admit in the
article essentially that they were lying
in the headline and it doesn't matter
because 90% of people will not actually
read the article alright which which is
why I would strongly recommend that if
you're going to it's a really basic
thing but if you're going to share
something on social media maybe take the
time to read it just take a couple a
couple of minutes it probably isn't very
long
they don't write long articles these
days because they know that we all have
the attention spans of squirrels so
take a couple of minutes and read it if
you're gonna show if you've got to take
the time to share it at least know it is
what it is you're sharing we always
complain about politicians who pass
bills right without reading it they're
gonna pass it without knowing what's in
it well we do the same thing we've
shared news articles and headlines and
we spread rumors and lies and stuff so
oftentimes unknowingly because we're
sharing stuff without actually knowing
what it is we're sharing which is kind
of mod my boggling and I don't really
get it what act what's the motivation I
mean what if you if you're so interested
in it that you feel like you have to let
your 500 Facebook friends know about it
if it's that interesting to you then why
wouldn't you read it and you can't claim
you can't say I don't have time to read
it and I'm so busy I'm so you're not
busy it's why you're on Facebook if
you're busy people aren't on Facebook
sharing news articles if you're doing
that it means you're not busy in fact
we're all a lot less busy than we
pretend we always try to use busyness as
a justification for our laziness
meanwhile we're you know we're all day
watching TV watching Netflix and so
we're so busy yet stranger things season
3 is gonna come out on July 4th and
we're all gonna watch like the whole
season in two days but we're so busy I'm
so busy oh my god I have no time for
anything I'm such a busy prat on sleep I
don't I'm so busy but oh yeah I watched
I watched literally ten hours of TV in
the last two days but I'm so busy right
all right um yeah let's see let's see
what else here I I wanted to play this
for you quickly this is a video I'm not
I'm not sure where it's from exactly
speaking of sharing things without
knowing what's in them well that's
because in this case it doesn't actually
matter this is obviously from some
preschool or kindergarten a graduation
ceremony and this was shared on Twitter
by a verified Twitter user named auntie
Anna it's what she goes by on Twitter
anyway who's a news editor for the roots
and she shared this vid
while apparently laughing hysterically
she said she shared it in the caption
that she that accompanied the the video
was I cannot stop laughing so that was
her caption she thinks it's hilarious
I'm not so sure that it is very funny
you tell me what you think here it is
[Music]
so the young boy looks to be I don't
know for maybe maybe five years old and
he shouts shut the eff up to his teacher
and then calls her the B word and as I
said some people find this funny it is
not it's not even a little bit funny
there's nothing funny about it this and
this is something that I see videos like
that and it takes me back not nostalgic
ly it takes me back to memories I don't
like to recall of my experience in
public school and I used to see this
thing all the time in public school and
I I went to a school that was supposedly
in the top 5% in the country
academically I believe yet this for 13
years of K through through 12
this this kind of thing was common where
you would have kids that would cuss out
teachers shut the F up call them the B
word verbally assault them sometimes
physically assault them common it was
common for me again in a supposedly good
high school can you you can only imagine
what goes on in schools that are let's
say in the bottom 5% academically and
this is what teachers deal with and they
deal with it now I watch that video and
my anger that I feel is number one
directed at the people who think it's
funny number two my anger is my anger is
not directed at the kid at all okay if
that kid was 17 years old then yeah I'd
have anger at the kid because you're old
enough at that point where you should
know better even if you weren't raised
to know better at a certain point you
got to start figuring it out as a as an
almost adult but as a 4 or 5 year old
kid you you only know what you've been
told by the adults around you you do and
say what you see and hear them doing and
saying so that you're you are a walking
reflection of what you see the adults
and other people around you doing that's
that's the case for anyone for any 4 or
5 year
so if they're acting it with if they're
acting horrific aliy like that then it
is 100% a reflection of how they're
raised so that kid now my so I have a I
have five well now they just turned six
I've got six year old kids I've been
we've got a an almost three year old
they they have their moments believe me
of acting out and being disrespectful
and which we work with them about that
we discipline them no kid is perfect I
am a hundred percent certain that my
kids would never ever talk to an adult
that way they wouldn't even know how to
talk to an adult that way if they ever
did talk to an adult that way the
consequences would be would be severe
but they never would I'm a hundred
percent certain they never would because
they just don't have that in them
because that we don't treat them that
way and we don't treat each other that
way they don't see it they're not around
it they wouldn't know to act that way so
if a kid is acting like that it's
because that's how he sees the adults in
his house acting and that's probably how
they act towards him if a kid is saying
shut the F up to an adult you can I
guarantee you that that he has been told
shut the F up by adults many times in
his life and that's why he's acting that
way so if you laugh at that in other
words this is a victim of neglect and
abuse 100% laughing at that is no
different than if that kid came in with
welts and bruises all over his face and
you left because that is well some
bruises on the face that's a sign of
abuse a kid acting like that is a sign
of abuse you are laughing at a sign of
abuse you are laughing at this kids
abuse and I can't imagine I just can't
this is what teachers have to deal with
you know I
am not shy about criticizing the public
school system I'm not shy about
criticizing teachers when they deserve
it and oftentimes they do but we also
have to acknowledge that teachers are
put in an impossible situation when they
have kids like that these are broken
children who have been broken by their
home environments and now they're coming
in and there's no control him what do
you do with a kid like that he's not
your kid but you only see him for a few
hours a day what do you do with him how
you can't control him is at the age of
five he already yes he does not kid has
absolutely no respect for authority at
all doesn't care what do you do as a
teacher there's nothing you can do and
this is the situation that the teachers
are being put in because of horrible
parents there are a lot of I know this
is not a news flash to you but there are
a lot of really really really bad
parents out there and they're sending
their kids to public school hoping that
the schools will do the parenting for
them and but schools can't do that the
school is just a building where you send
your kid for a few hours a day they get
cannot it's a system it's a you know
it's a it's a bureaucracy essentially it
cannot be a parent and so if you're not
gonna do it if you're not gonna do the
job of parenting your kid then that's a
job that just isn't getting done because
no one else can do it unless you put
them up for adoption there's not anyone
else who can step in and do it it's
either you were nobody all right I'm
very sad very sad video so you got to
pray it pray for that kid I need
something to lighten the mood how about
this representative Jerry Nadler who's a
Democrat was questioning hope Hicks in a
Judiciary Committee Committee hearing
yesterday and he kept calling hope Hicks
miss Lewandowski
referring to corey lewandowski now some
people think that it was disrespectful
and sexist he was doing it on purpose
disrespecting her by calling her miss
Lewandowski something that he's just
losing his mind and there's no idea
what's going on I tend to maybe side
with the ladder because of this look at
this picture here so look I don't mean I
don't mean to laugh I just I can't I'm
that's the most amazing picture I've
ever seen this is this is Jerry Nadler I
have never seen that much pants on one
person that's the most pants I've ever
seen on a person ever and I where do you
even buy pants like that
where do you go if I wanted to get those
pants I go to the maternity section I
guess I've never seen anything like I'm
sorry to laugh I just that is that's
amazing that is a look at these guys
pants up to his neck how is that even
now I put this on Twitter and I had some
people lecturing me saying that I'm you
know it's it's mean and I'm mocking him
and mocking the elderly first of all
it's not about him being elderly I you
know I know that older people tend to
wear their pants up higher nothing wrong
with that and but but look I've never
I've seen a lot of old people mile I've
never seen pants like that I've never
seen that that looks physically
impossible and I'm not mocking him it's
I but it's it's it's a remarkable
picture that I just have to cheer that
yes I'm making fun of them a little bit
but it is hilarious you have to admit
really though my point is compassion yes
that's what it is
I'm being compassionate what I'm trying
to say is yeah you called Hope Hicks mr.
Lewandowski three times it seems like
it's being disrespectful but then think
about those pants if a person
he knows what's going on do they wear
pants like that probably not so have
some patience with him is all I'm trying
to say I didn't even maybe he made pants
out of a it's like a like it took a
blimp or something and cut up a blimp
and made pants out of it I I can't it's
incredible all right let's move on to
two emails Matt wall show at gmail.com
Matt wall show at gmail.com and hint I
was I keep thinking about the pants it's
hilarious sorry this is from Thomas says
hi Matt I was talking to a friend a
while ago when we somehow got on the
topic of music she and I have relatively
the same taste in music classic rock
except for one thing she actually enjoys
the band Nickelback I absolutely cannot
wrap my mind around how somebody could
like a band that makes multiple songs
that sound so alike and aren't even that
good I came to you to settle this too
but to settle this debate that has
lasted for months so with the world and
left us destroying knowledge please tell
me is Nickelback a good band well of
course Thomas you're right you you are
correct they are not a good band they're
a terrible band they're very bad however
I will say that I think they're not
nearly as bad as they're made out to be
and I don't mean that as they're bad
don't get me wrong I just mean that they
have been the punching bag of the music
scene for the last 10 years and they
endure so much ridicule I almost have to
respect them that do they still make
music because there's two other still
Nickelback songs out there if they do I
really respect that they've been a punch
line a punching bag and a punch line for
10 years and they're still cracking
they're still making music they're still
going at it so I respect it I just think
I think they're they're very bad band
they make bad music but there are a lot
of bands and musical acts that are worse
than them I'd put them in the bottom
like 40 percent you know but there
so there are a whole bunch of bands that
are worse that don't endure any we're in
close to the same amount of ridicule and
that to me is simply unfair what I guess
what I'm trying to say is let's spread
our ridicule around spread the ridicule
around be more egalitarian be more we
need to be equal in our dispensing of
ridicule to bad bands and not and not
foist it all along
Nickelback all right uh let's see what
else we got here this is from Nick says
hey hello mr. Walsh I've recently become
a listener and huge fan of your show
this is in spite of the fact that I'm
blind thus I cannot even cast my eyes
upon your stunning appearance and your
famed beard my dad is an atheist and I
have been a Christian for about four
years we were discussing an argument
that objective morality could not exist
without the existence of God he thinks
that the ideas of right and wrong could
have come about through evolution and
what was most beneficial to the survival
of the human species as evidence he
cited the most intelligent monkey slash
ape species who seemed to live in a
fairly ordered social structure yet do
not have the rational capacities that
humans do he thinks they still have the
same that they still have some sense
that killing stealing etc is wrong what
do you think about the idea that
morality could come about through
evolution alone why would we evolve to
do what's best for the species as a
whole rather than looking out for
ourselves only in a Hobbesian state of
nature any good authors you know of on
the subject so I think there are a few
problems Nick with the theory that
morality evolved first of all yes your
dad mentioned some Apes who seemed to
have rudimentary some rudimentary moral
sense I'm not sure I agree with that I
think we tend to anthropomorphize
animals and sometimes we'll see animals
doing something or acting in a certain
way and we'll assume well we'll we'll
kind of imbue human qualities into it
where I think it's not really
appropriate for instance you'll see a
picture of an animal kind of stained
ending over a dead animal and we'll
think oh is that so sweet he's weeping
over the animal he's mourning the loss
of his fellow Fox or dog or whatever
maybe there's something like that going
on but maybe not maybe he's just about
to eat the things body I mean it's it's
that's probably more what's happening
there
so but any case what we certainly know
is that no other species has the
capacity to formulate the kind of
sophisticated moral system that we have
we are the only species with a
sophisticated moral system we're the
only species that's capable of real
benevolence and also the only species
capable of real cruelty and that's why
for all that your dad says about well
look at apes and monkeys well I would
ask your dad does he think that if an
ape kills another ape we should put the
ape in jail what about it when an ape
has sex with another ape without getting
consent first so we put him in jail for
rape
should we start trying animals I'm
thinking your dad would say no that's
ridiculous and why would he say no he
would I assume say well I could put it
you can't put a monkey or an ape in jail
for murder I don't know what they're
doing they don't have the same sense
that we do they're not they don't have
the same awareness they don't have the
same culpability well yes exactly
we're the only ones with that
culpability but that's kind of weird
from an evolutionary perspective because
of this kind of thing just evolves by
chance it would seem mathematically
certain that other species would evolve
it to yet none have millions of species
on earth were the only ones who evolved
this rather peculiar ability to see
right and wrong or I guess - from an
evolutionary standpoint if there's no
God to invent the concepts of right and
wrong it seems odd that we're the only
ones who did that also from a purely
evolutionary standpoint remember the
only point of life is
reproduce and sustain the species and
the idea behind evolution is that those
qualities which help towards the
propagation of the species and the
survival of species those qualities are
going to be passed on while quality is
that interfere with propagation and
survival will die away and that's
because as the theory goes if a certain
member of a species has certain
qualities due to whatever genetic
mutations or whatever that caused him to
act in a way that's more advantageous
for survival and propagation well then
he's going to survive and he's going to
reproduce whereas those that lack the
quality will die off quicker and then
that sort of strand will fade away while
his trend will continue and then that's
how you have evolution through natural
selection and without a god then that's
all that's going on there's no there's
no guiding force there's no intelligent
design there's nothing like that it's
just it's pure blind evolution and genes
kind of doing what they do on their own
well if that's the case then we have to
ask what about something like rape rape
propagates the species rape has
evolutionary advantages and that's why
with many species of animals Wraith is
the only way basic now we don't call it
rape again because they don't have the
culpability that we do but for sake of
argument for a lot of species of animals
rape is the only way that they that they
reproduce you'll see in a lot of species
the male dominates the female there's no
consent or anything whether the female
wants to or not
dominates the female and reproduces yet
with our in our species we have
this idea that it's wrong now it seems
to me that it shouldn't have worked that
way if it's all about evolution Genghis
Khan has 16 million descendants today
0.5% the population is descended from
this one guy 8% of the guys and of the
men in in the Mongolia area are related
to him why because he went around raping
and pillaging
he raped hundreds if not thousands of
women he propagated the species more
than probably anyone else on earth so we
see again the evolutionary advantages of
sexual domination he was able to spread
his seed as it were across the entire
world he is 16 million descendants yet
yet we still instill as a society have
have developed this idea we believe or I
would say we haven't developed the idea
we recognize the truth that rape is
wrong every society every culture
condemns it even though it still is it
still happens in every culture but how
is that the body by the evolutionary
model the pro rape folks like Genghis
Khan should have passed on their pro
rape genes and created a whole human
race full of pro rape people
after all again these are the people who
had the easiest time propagating
reproducing they're passing on those
genes and that's all you have is just
the material right genes genetics and so
that's where everything stems from even
morality and so that's how evolution is
supposed to work it seems to me by the
evolutionary model we should now live in
a society much like many animal
societies where a rape is completely
commonplace and normal and nobody thinks
anything of it but that's not the way it
goes why I think it's because there's a
higher truth there's a guiding principle
there's a guiding light that we
recognize and see and follow there is
something above our savage animal
instinctive nature something above it
which we are reaching
for striving for aspiring to and I would
call that something God so that's how I
would respond to that let's see if
there's anything else this is from Jake
hi Matt I've only recently picked up on
your show and I'm kicking myself for not
doing it sooner
hearing Bernie Sanders views on a
socialist United States was would look
like what it would look like has me
deeply scared of what would happen if he
somehow got voted into office to me it's
reminiscent of how in Batman Begins Liam
Neeson wants to see Gotham fall just
because it's too great I would like to
hear your opinion on what would happen
if Bernie were voted in and started to
implement socialist policies would there
be a violent resistance or would people
protest how would the left or right
respond would the free market somehow
survive or would America be in shambles
I tend to Jake I I want to believe in
the resiliency of the American idea of
democracy and FreeMarkets but I tend to
think that that would we would be in
shambles
where we would be very close to it if we
had an actual straight-up socialist
president in office and I think the
problem is and this is what the
socialists know and the people that
support the entitlement stay at the
nanny state which of these are all
socialist ideas what they know is that
yeah conceptually people will protest
that people don't like it when you look
at it just as an abstract idea there are
a lot of problems and people don't like
it but if you can shove it down their
throats anyway and if you can if you can
just get it in there if you can if you
can if you can establish it anyway then
people will quickly become dependent on
it and once they're dependent on it
they're not going to want you to take it
away and we found this time and again
with entitlement systems whether it's
Social Security or welfare food stamps
Obama care once yep you have an argument
about it people don't like it they
protest
once it's in though once you've started
it you've gotten people on it there
and now you have them and you can breed
an entire country of dependent people
we're already basically there so I think
that having a socialist president would
kind of be I hate using this expression
but it would kind of be the nail in the
coffin
and so I'm very worried about that as
well I wish I could give you a more a
more positive optimistic view but that's
that's it have a good weekend though
anyway we'll leave it there and hope you
have a great weekend thanks for watching
thanks for listening
Godspeed today on the Ben Shapiro show
President Trump has jets in the air
ready to bomb the Iranians and he calls
it off we'll talk about why that's today
on the bench Shapiro show